nearly one out of every 13 children
reportedly has a food allergy families
with severe allergies often rely on
those EpiPens to deliver a dose of
potentially life-saving medicine if a
child has a very bad reaction but the
cost of the EpiPen is surging putting
the pinch on many families the
auto-injectors price has risen by more
than four hundred and eighty percent
since 2009 but a denier introduces us to
a family we just felt every bit of that
increase Vanita good morning good
morning this is a training device
families used to practice what to do in
the event of an emergency they simply
remove the safety cap and push the
EpiPen into the thigh the real thing is
filled with epinephrine which can
counter the effects of a severe allergic
reaction the actual cost of the drug
inside the EpiPen is only a couple of
bucks so the manufacturer is essentially
charging hundreds of dollars for a case
and a trusted name an EpiPen is never
far away in the head of your household
or dinnertime so this is our Mexican
pizza is a cautious time of the family
six children to have severe food
allergies three-year-old Cora and
seven-year-old le le has a laundry list
of foods to avoid dairy wheat soy eggs
peanuts tree nuts sesame seeds it's why
both girls never leave their
Indianapolis area home without their
fanny pack it's always good to have it
so you can get really sick if you don't
have that with you as a baby Ellie's
allergic reactions were so severe hives
covered her entire body
her family has twice used the EpiPen to
save her life her lips turned blue
she started swelling she wasn't able to
breathe they have to replace the
injectors every year when they expire
the hen Agurs remember paying as little
as $80 for them five or six years ago
before they switched to a high
deductible health plan we really noticed
it in the past year year and a half when
we went to go have it filled it was 600
when the pharmacist first told you the
bill did you think you must be wrong I
did I had her look it up again and she
didn't have to because she had answered
that question many times with many other
people who asked her this
in question of are you sure but the
EpiPen is that expensive and and it is
in 2009 pharmacies paid slightly more
than $100 for a two pack of epi pens the
price has since skyrocketed to more than
$600
if they don't have it it could mean life
or death pharmacist Leon Tarasenko says
the high prices are forcing some
families to take risks within the last
two months we've had about three
patients who had issues with the price
of an epi pen and we actually they did
not receive it they just refused to take
it
Bloomberg senior medical reporter Robert
languorous says the manufacturer of the
device Milan has a virtual monopoly
after its main competitor launched a
recall last fall this brand name at the
pen it's like Kleenex - allergist say
you know it's a name they know and trust
it's what they prescribed he says the
company has remarketed the decades-old
device without making any significant
changes since acquiring it in 2007 I
couldn't read but I had it with me and
used it immediately it's spent tens of
millions of dollars on TV ads and
donated the device to schools across the
u.s. ensuring it was a familiar product
it's a totally established brand name
with little competition that gives them
freedom to raise the price every year in
a statement Milan tells CBS News the
EpiPens price has changed over time to
better reflect important product
features and the value the product
provides saying we've made a significant
investment to support the device over
the past years are you fearful the price
could continue to go up yes prices are
based on competition and there's no
competition
the company offers coupons which have
allowed many patients to pay nothing
out-of-pocket those coupons are worth up
to $100 so families with high
deductibles like the hen Agurs are still
on the hook for the majority of the cost
that really cornered the market yeah
when you need it you need it but that's
an awful 8 from 80 to 600 in that period
of time let's talk about the families
benita thank you